gefunden hat und es kann sein dass ihr
jetzt schon auf dem neuen zdf- heute-
youtube kanal seite erst noch ziemlich
klein aber würden uns freuen wenn ihr
uns ein abo da last denn wir werden
zukünftig von da aus scream jetzt sind
wir noch mal zumindest wenn ihr auf
youtube zukunft auf dem zdf dach kanal
das wird sich aber zumindest auf youtube
ändern also keinen livestream mehr
verpassen und keine neuesten nachrichten
mehr verpassen dann einmal bitte zu
youtube gehen ansonsten stehen wir auch
weiter natürlich auf teleskop in der zdf
mediathek auf der heute de und auf
facebook so das war die offizielle
ankündigung kommen wir jetzt zum
inhaltlichen teil
die landtagswahl in brandenburg und
sachsen ist seit gestern nämlich
geschichte und da hat sich doch einiges
bewegt zumindest das was sich bewegen
kann in richtung wählerstimmen dass die
afg dort ziemlich deutlich dominieren
würde das hat sich schon vor anleihen
abgezeichnet aber dass es so deutlich
werden wird da hat doch einige menschen
sich sehr gewundert auf platz zwei sind
sie einmal in brandenburg und einmal in
sachsen gelandet und man kann auch hier
in den zahlen sehen das ist hellblau die
zahl der gewonnenen direktmandate in
sachsen das ist doch eine relativ
deutliche dominanz
das sieht auch ähnlich in brandenburg so
aus das ganze ist jetzt nicht zum ersten
mal so bei der letzten bundestagswahl
das ja schon bundestagswahl weil das ja
auch schon so die afg ist die stärkste
opposition im bundestag bei der wahl zum
europaparlament war das so aber jetzt
eben wieder dh dreimal ist kein zufall
mehr und da stellt sich eben die frage
ist die afg eine neue rechte volkspartei
das wollen heute diskutieren mit euch
zusammen und mit meinen beiden kollegen
thomas bärsch eben landesstudio sachsen
und nicole diekmann im in berlin im
hauptstadtstudio oder besser vom
reichstag heute abend und wir fangen an
mit thomas bärsch in sachsen der ist mir
es zugeschaltet auf seiner terrasse da
im landesstudio thomas wann hast du denn
diesen erfolg der afd kommen sehen sein
werden
hartz4 und als reaktion in sachsen die
npd in den landtag mit zehn prozent
hier war aber konsens dass es sich
wirklich um eine protestwahl handelt die
inhalte haben damals nicht viele geteilt
ich erinnere mich an 2013 als die afg
aufkam als euro-skeptischen partei das
hat sich deutlich anders angefühlt
die partei wurde damals getragen von
dieser euro-skepsis von dem gefühl dass
der staat dinge regelt die hier nicht
mehr besprochen werden man hat das
gefühl gehabt dass wird über die köpfe
hinaus entschieden und man hatte das
gefühl dass man über diese dinge nicht
reden darf ohne dass man in gefahr gerät
in eine ecke gestellt zu werden also wer
sich als euro skeptiker outete hatte
angst dass jemand kommt und sagt du bist
in der rechten ecke zu suchen ich
erinnere mich an meinen rund gefühl der
ohnmacht dass ich selber schwierigkeiten
hatte mich dort zu vermitteln und auch
durchzudringen und ich war erschrocken
etwas angesichts dieses monolithischen
glaube dass es so ist als dann 2014 päda
aufkam und den begriff der lösung presse
kultivierte und als dann 2015 die
flüchtlingskrise kam die die den bei den
fdp anhängern auch wirkte wie ein stark
der die sache nicht im griff hat wie
eine bestätigung all der befürchtungen
die die fdp formulierte und kultivierte
also da wird wahrscheinlich nicht nur
ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht nur ich
gedacht haben dass hier etwas entstanden
ist was nicht mehr so schnell geht das
haben wir jetzt gesehen dh zum dritten
mal dass die afg in wahlen ziemlich
stark geworden unter anderem zum
beispiel in einer gemeinde da ist es
schon länger so dass dort rechte die
macht oder viele stimmen bekommen
hirschfeld heißt dies ist eine davon zb
im landkreis elbe elster hat die afg 50
prozent der zweitstimmen erhalten nicht
zum ersten mal muss man sagen aber
diesmal halt wieder und nancy fischer
war für uns dort
spätsommer idylle im südlichen
brandenburg hier liegt hirschfeld an der
grenze zu sachsen in dem 1200 einwohner
ort hat gestern jeder zweite seine
stimme der afg gegeben
es ändert sich nicht viel und wenn man
bei uns kleinen arbeiten sieht es wird
immer mehr abgezogen und ich haben ohne
jobs kann man kaum noch ein kind
ernähren
darum geht es und das frustet im
normalen arbeiter ebenfalls extra das
liegt wahrscheinlich doch daran dass die
infrastruktur hier am boden liegt naja
ich fand das nicht empfehlen das macht
er immer mehr
mehr kann ich dazu möchte dabei gibt es
in hirschfeld keinen einzigen flüchtling
und alle bus der vor über 20 jahren nach
brandenburg kam ist mit seinem laden
hier auch akzeptiert aber warum wurde
herschfeld zur afg hochburg das
beschäftigt auch die bürgermeisterin
yvonne haase und den amtsdirektor tilo
richter beiden ist wichtig der ort soll
jetzt nicht in die rechte ecke gestellt
werden
ich denke einfach das ist nicht die
politik die wir hier unten machen
sondern das ist die bundespolitik also
die die bürger fühlen sich allein
gelassen fühlen sich nicht mehr
verstanden
wir haben potenzial wir haben
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten und die wollen
wir gerne nutzen und es hilft uns
niemand das ist uns überhaupt nicht
damit geholfen wenn wir noch schranken
eingezogen bekommen dass wir uns nicht
entwickeln kann das stichwort ist das
saarland nach wie vor
es fehlt also an bauland in hirschfeld
dafür ist die landesregierung zuständig
sonst fehlt es an nicht viel
es gibt zwei bäcker ein metzger und ein
kaufhaus einen kindergarten und die
grundschule dazu kultur und
sportangebote aber die unzufriedenheit
bleibt und volker moting profitiert
davon
der direktkandidat im landkreis elbe
elster hat seinen wahlkreis gewonnen
unter anderem mit dem motto vollende die
wende ist ja für uns dass wir schon
mittlerweile parallelen zur ddr zeit vor
30 jahren entdecken meinungsfreiheit das
ist ein ganz großes beispiel mein herz
immer wieder auch an unseren vorständen
sind die bürger relativ und zufrieden
dass man sich schon wieder überlegen
muss was man so erzählt es gibt auch
hirschfelder die mit dem erfolg der
rechtspopulisten nicht einverstanden
sind vor der kamera wollte uns das heute
aber niemand sagen ja darüber reden wir
heute unter anderem mit meinem kollegen
thomas desch im landesstudio sachsen
hier ist aber schon eine frage von euch
gestellt wurden die möchte ich ganz kurz
beantworten nämlich von assist zum
lachen noch periskop die frage warum
wird die ganze zeit von der afg geredet
da müssen wir einfach feststellen die
afg ist eine relativ junge partei die
die parteienlandschaft in deutschland
ziemlich aufgemischt hat jetzt in
brandenburg und sachsen die
zweitstärkste partei geworden ist da
müssen wir als journalisten und wollen
wir natürlich auch darüber reden oder
berichten und uns fragen warum das so
ist und da ist eine frage gleich undicht
thomas du hast ja gerade einen film
gemacht eine längere doku zum
lebensgefühl der sachsen und zum frust
auch teilweise herrscht was ist da sogar
eine quintessenz das dabei
herausgekommen wie passt das zu diesem
wahlergebnis
ja das ist natürlich ein großes thema
und das ist aber ein beherrschendes
thema wenn man sich lange und viel mit
leuten unterhält die auch verstärkt auch
wieder mit uns reden die bei längeren
gesprächen dann doch nachdem sie eine
weile geschimpft haben auf alles dann
plötzlich dann doch erzählen wollen und
es erscheint mir schon so dass hier viel
um erzählt geblieben ist die menschen
fühlen sich so dass sie wahnsinnige um
brüche erlitten haben die aber noch
niemanden interessiert haben die wollen
gerne erzählen was sie erlebt haben und
sie wollen auch erzählen wie sie sich
durch dieses tal durchgekämpft haben und
ziehen entwickeln aber auch so ein
gefühl wenn sie jetzt zurückblicken auf
ihr leben auf ihre zeit sind auch schon
teilweise ein bisschen älter dann sagen
sie sie haben 40 jahren ddr gelebt mehr
schlecht als recht haben die ganze zeit
gewusst es gibt ein anderes deutschland
ihm geht es wirtschaftlich besser als
uns im osten und hat sich möglicherweise
damit getröstet dass man es war im
ärmeren aber in besseren gerechteren
sozialeren deutschland lebt und dann
plötzlich fällt die mauer und das andere
deutschland ist da und man ist selber
schon 40 jahre alt muss irgendwie gucken
dass man im kapitalismus zurechtkommt
macht verschiedene jobs nicht arbeitslos
macht nicht die große karriere und
blickt jetzt am ende seines berufslebens
am anfang des renten lebens auf rente
zurück die eben dann doch nicht so
richtig reicht und hier hat sich
möglicherweise bei vielen ein gefühl
eingeschnitten dass das leben praktisch
verloren ist dass sich keiner für dieses
gefühl interessiert und uns hat mal in
chemnitz war das glaube ich hat mal
einer gesagt ja es ist so wir sind
deutsche zweiter klasse und als die
flüchtlinge kamen haben wir gemerkt dass
plötzlich so viel geld da ist was früher
nicht da war für jeden um jeden renten
punkt musste wirklich sehr verhandelt
werden und plötzlich kommt eine eine
krise und wie schon bei der
bankenrettung da war es auch so dass
geld da war jetzt plötzlich ist wieder
geld da und man hat
das gefühlt so hat man es mir erzählt
dass man plötzlich eben nicht mehr
deutschlands zweite klasse ist natürlich
deutschland
aber es ist doch viel geld in osten
geflossen und es sind ja auch gerade
junge leute die die afg jetzt gewählt
haben also ist ja nicht nur rentner
partei wenn wir uns angucken wer da
gewählt hat was ist denn da das
lebensgefühl die haben ihr leben noch
vor sich über wasser zu halten und das
was eltern am küchentisch sagen das
verfestigt sich natürlich auch bei denen
die jetzt nachkommen dieses gefühl
deutsche zweiter klasse zu sein steigt
bei jungen leuten auch wieder an das
haben umfragen gezeigt
und dieses gefühl dieses gefühl versteht
die afg natürlich auch aufzugreifen und
mit solchen slogans wie wir haben es
gehört vollendet die wände zu bedienen
was ist denn mit diesem slogan gemeint
kannst du das mal kurz zusammenfassen
das klingt ja so ein bisschen so als ob
die wende nicht vollendet wäre ja also
es geht wieder um das was ich vorhin
gesagt habe dieses gefühl
damals konnte man nicht alles sagen und
damals war alles von oben vorgegeben und
das sei jetzt auch wieder so hier hier
erscheint ein großes missverständnis
vorzuherrschen also dieses gefühl ich
kann nicht alles sagen weil ihr sonst
erleide ich repressionen das ist
natürlich anders gemeint heute als es
damals nach damals wehrmann vermutlich
wenn man sich staatsfeindlich geäußert
hätte irgendwo eingefahrene heute kann
es natürlich sein dass man wenn man sich
staatsfeindlich oder so äußert dass es
widerspruch ausgelöst dass man diesen
widerspruch auch erfährt und wenn dieser
widerspruch sich gesellschaftlich
organisiert in vereinen die zb sich
gegen einen trainer aus sprechen der
sich in einer art und weise äußert mit
der sich dieser verein zum beispiel
nicht identifizieren will
ja dann wird der verein das diesem
trainer auch so mitteilen und ihnen
vielleicht auch seines amtes entheben
und dass dieser trainer dann sagt das
ist jetzt ja so wie damals in der ddr
und das dann eine partei kommt gesagt
vollendet die wende und mit uns darfst
du alles sagen was du willst
das ist dann für diesen einen vereins
trainer der sich so geäußert hat dann
vielleicht nachvollziehbar und aus
dieser sicht auch zu verstehen aber es
ist natürlich wenn man es aus objektiver
sicht sieht immer noch was anderes ob
man heute seine meinung frei äussert was
ja auch immer wieder und immer lauter
getan wird als wenn man es damals getan
hätte und echte repressionen zu tragen
hätte es geht also vor allem sehr er
nehme ich es seinen worten um gefühle um
das gefühl nicht gesehen nicht
verstanden zu werden und auch irgendwie
nicht wahrgenommen zu werden
wir haben erst mal guckt was es dann
noch für gründe gibt die afg zu wählen
darf eine flieger hat dass wir uns
zusammengefasst
schwarz und blau
die neue politische landkarte in sachsen
besteht vor allem aus zwei farben die
afg gewinnt nach der cdu die meisten
direktmandate und welche gründe geben
die fdp an
70 prozent in sachsen antworten die afg
wegen ihrer politischen forderungen
gewählt zu haben 28 prozent sprechen von
einem denkzettel
auch die karte in brandenburg teilt sich
nach der landtagswahl in vor allem zwei
farben auf rot und blau
die spd musste zwar verluste hinnehmen
bleibt aber stärkste
kraft und hier geben 53 prozent der
befragten an die fdp als denkzettel welt
zu haben
43 prozent sagen dagegen die wahl fiel
wegen ihrer inhalte auf die ofd
auffällig rechtsfällen vor allem die
ländlichen regionen sagt auch professor
gideon botsch politikwissenschaftler an
der uni potsdam
hier muss man den demokratischen
parteien meines lebens tatsächlich
vorhalten dass sie sich oft aus dieser
fläche auswahl arithmetischen gründen
zurückziehen dass sie meinen hier finden
wir ohnehin nicht genug wählerinnen und
wähler da müssen wir gar nicht im
wahlkampf freien und hier dürfte
durchaus eine erfolgreiche kampagne
gefahren
aber wer wählt die fdp bei den
bundesländern ist sie bei männern
deutlich erfolgreicher als bei frauen
sieht man sich die altersgruppen an ist
die fd in beiden bundesländern bei den
wählern unter 60 jahren mit abstand die
stärkste partei
gründe für ihren erfolg protest
benachteiligung und unzufriedenheit in
brandenburg sagen 46 prozent der fdp
wähler haben im leben weniger als ihnen
gerechterweise zusteht
in sachsen sagen 70 prozent die
ostdeutschen werden behandelt wie bürger
zweiter klasse
das ist natürlich tatsächlich so dass
wir im osten einige benachteiligungen
zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
das fängt mit dem unterschiedlichen
löhne und gehälter dabei gleich ein
wenig höheren preisniveau an mit
infrastruktur problemen und förderung
problemen wie viele bundesbehörden gibt
es in den neuen ländern und so weiter
und so fort ja wie viele der post origin
hauptstädte sind überhaupt noch mit pc
angeschlossen dann müssen sie wie
beispielsweise nach schwerin oder
magdeburg den regionalexpress nehmen das
sind natürlich alles faktoren die die
dakar zu buche schlagen und woher kommen
die neuen stimmen für die afd
von früheren cdu wählern und von
früheren nichtwählern keine andere
partei profitiert also so stark von der
gestiegenen wahlbeteiligung bietet afd
das thema spaltet unsere
kommentarspalten
interessanterweise tatsächlich nach
netzwerk so auf youtube ist es relativ
klar pro afd da gibt es einen kommentare
wie die afg ist die letzte hoffnung für
das vaterland
auf facebook ist es relativ eindeutig
gegen die afg da kommen einem kommentare
wie die afg ist rechtsextremistische und
verfassungsfeindlich und ähnlich sieht
das auch bei plus gruppe aus so ich
spreche noch mal mit thomas bärsch über
dieses thema im landesstudio sind
herzlich fiel mit beschäftigt mit diesem
komplex wie ist denn die wahrnehmung bei
euch in sachsen wie hast du das erlebt
wird die afg als volkspartei
wahrgenommen oder als protestpartei
handwerkerverein viele verschiedene
bildungsschichten
aber sie ist als volkspartei natürlich
nicht so breit aufgestellt wie sie das
sein sollte sie ist dann doch sehr
eingeengt aber sie wird als volkspartei
wahrgenommen wenigstens von denen die
sie wählen und bestimmt auch von denen
die sie die ihr beigetreten sind
und wenn ihr da mehr zu dem thema wissen
möchtet und die tasche von thomas noch
mal angucken wollte ist noch in der zdf
mediathek thomas auch noch mal kurz wie
sie heißt die heißt zwischen mauerfall
und rechtspopulismus sachsen eine
spurensuche es gibt auch einen längeren
artikel vielleicht kann man noch mal
ganz kurz zeigen hier auf meinem rechner
habe ich ihn aufgemacht den hast du im
juli geschrieben auf den spuren des
sachsen frustes 30 jahre nach dem
mauerfall da ist der link auch zu den
artikeln drin einfach mal suchen nach
thomas bärsch sachsen mauerfall und dann
könnt ihr das finden so thomas vielen
dank für deine zeit du musst noch ein
journal glaube ich machen und hat ein
bisschen was zu tun deswegen
verabschieden werde ich jetzt erstmal
und schalten aber rüber zu unserer
kollegin nach berlin gleich denn das
ergebnis hat ja ziemlich für aufregung
gesorgt bundesweit dabei ist nicht das
erste mal dass er so viele stimmen
bekommt aber der flügelkampf in der afg
der da doch seit einiger zeit herrscht
der wird natürlich dadurch jetzt noch
weiter angeheizt und britta buchholz
zeigt uns mal was damit gemeint ist
es ist auch ihr abend die landeschefs
kalbitz und hugo triumphieren es ist der
abend der die afg verändern wird und
nicht nur sie ist nicht zu ende
der kampf geht heute erst los aber wir
sind sehr viel stärker geworden uns
kriegt man aus der deutschen politik
nicht mehr weg da bleiben wir
die deutlichste konsequenz für die afd
das erstarken des flügels kalbitz urban
höcker spitzen figuren des flügels
jährlicher höhepunkt das sogenannte
kyffhäuser treffen wie hier 2008 zehnter
der flüge gilt als nationalistisch
völkisch der verfassungsschutz stuft ihn
als verdachtsfall für
rechtsextremistische bestrebungen ein
die partei bemüht sich in klein zu reden
auch heute da gibt es also nicht mit
machtübernahme der einen oder der
anderen seite wir sind bei allen
differenzen über den einzelpositionen
haben müssen das thüringer
rentenpapieren anderes als mainz oder so
sind wir doch eine partei und 3 dabei
wird es bleiben insofern sehe ich das
sehr entspannt
doch die ergebnisse erhöhen den
machtanspruch der ostländer im november
die wichtige neuwahl des gesamten
bundesvorstandes der flügel wird im
vorstand keine nebenrolle mehr
akzeptieren und macht das auch
unmissverständlich klar
natürlich möchte ich dass der osten auch
gordon personell besser repräsentiert
ist das ist sicherlich eine konsequenz
aus diesen ostwall in die internen
konflikte
sie wachsen der flügel stellt sich
beispielsweise gegen
parteiausschlussverfahren ebenso
polarisiert das thema
regierungsbeteiligung die bundesspitze
fordert die cdu dagegen zum umdenken auf
und bezeichnet sich selbst als
bürgerliche kraft
ich habe gestern in einer rede völlig
richtig für eine bürgerliche politik
geworden denn es gibt eine bürgerliche
mehrheit in diesem land und zu der
gehören bier und darüber spreche ich
jetzt in berlin mit meiner kollegin
nicole diekmann der sich auch schon
lange und viel mit der afg beschäftigt
hat das ist eine unheimliche dynamik die
da gerade in der partei steckt was
passiert da jetzt gerade was nützt
dieser machtkampf aus
dieser machtkampf löst schon seit
einigen wochen große große unruhe aus
und allen beschwichtigungen heute zum
trotz wird das jetzt weitergehen denn
mit kalbitz und urban haben zwei
mitglieder des flügels gewonnen mit
kalbitz ein bedeutendes wenn ich das
bedeutet es damit geht des flügels ist
immer nicht ganz klar wer da eigentlich
der anführer ist er oder blöcke und
bernd höcker der hat in sieben wochen
bahn in thüringen da ist er
spitzenkandidat also er so sagt man das
herz des flügels und kalbitz das hirn
und das was jetzt dieses wochenende
passiert ist in brandenburg und in
sachsen das gibt natürlich auch nochmal
rückenwind für einen möglichen
wahlerfolg am 17 oktober und dann dann
geht die diskussion innerhalb der partei
erst richtig los da gerade im beitrag
schon gehört es geht um den
bundesvorstand
es geht aber nicht nur um posten sondern
es geht um stimmungen es geht um einen
ruck weiter nach rechts der partei und
der ist heute noch einmal weiter
eingeleitet worden kann das wirklich
passieren dass dieser flügel so viel
macht bekommt das die komplette afd
in dieser sache sehr stark eindeutig
rechte rechtsextreme ecke sagen manche
kit das kann passieren klar wenn wir uns
ein paar landesverbände angucken wie zum
beispiel schleswig holstein da ist jetzt
gerade das schlimmste aus sicht des
bundesvorstandes verhindert worden eine
flügelfrau eine enge vertraute von
höcker zu sayn wittgenstein sayn
wittgenstein tschuldigung die war
die steckte schon lange in einem
parteiausschlussverfahren und inmitten
dieses parteiausschlussverfahren das hat
der landesverband schleswig holstein die
noch mal schnell zu landes vertreten der
vorsitzenden gewählt und als dann letzte
woche der finale parteiausschluss
verkündet wurde hieß es erst
ausschließlich forscher nur dar und
würde man sich nicht halten
das hat man jetzt zurückgenommen sie
tritt ab sagt von sayn-wittgenstein aber
das ist nur ein beispiel von mehreren
landesverbänden in denen im moment
richtig was los ist in nordrhein
westfalen hat es vor ein paar wochen
gekracht genau deswegen wegen des
streits zwischen flügel und den
sogenannten gemäßigten also es ist
überall in sehr vielen landesverbänden
eben auch im westen
das heißt das ist überhaupt noch nicht
geklärt es ist überhaupt nicht klar dass
diese partei nicht weiter nach rechts
rückt die afg nimmt er für sich in
anspruch volkspartei zu sein nennt sich
auch selber bürgerlich aber wofür steht
sie denn genau inhaltlich inhaltlich
steht sie für protest
wenn man das mal so freundlich
formulieren will ich nenne mal ein
beispiel am freitag war
abschlusskundgebung in königs
wusterhausen nicht weiter entfernt von
berlin in brandenburg unterstanden urban
höcker und kallwitz auf der bühne und
alle drei hatten drei themen das erste
war die presse die sogenannte gez presse
das geht also gegen uns alle drei haben
immer wieder und das gab immer wieder
frenetischen applaus darauf hingewiesen
sei die rft irgendwann an der macht dann
würden die staatsverträge aufgelöst also
im klartext man will uns abschaffen es
geht generell gegen die presse
vergangenen freitag sind ja nochmal
enthüllungen im spiegel öffentlich
geworden nämlich dass kalbitz vor
ungefähr zwölf jahren dabei gewesen ist
in griechenland mit einer gruppe von
rechtsextremisten als eine hakenkreuz
flagge gehisst worden ist die
verteidigungslinie ist jetzt er selber
habe die ja nicht gehisst also und das
war nicht das erste mal dass seine
verbindung ins rechtsextreme milieu
angesprochen worden sind und ist auch
wirklich nicht richtige belege dagegen
gab das bedeutet die presse ist der afg
ein dorn im auge wenn gleich sie auch
vor keinem mikrofon zurückscheut und
sich gerne von uns auch interviewen
lässt auch mit uns zusammenarbeitet das
kann ich nach der zeit hier im
hauptstadtstudio sagen
das zweite thema das eine große rolle
gespielt hat vergangenen freitag war die
rente und da wird es ganz interessant da
hat mir ein höcke nämlich gesagt also im
gegensatz zu den altparteien wie es ja
immer heißt habe die afg ein
rentenkonzept und das stimmt einfach
nicht
die afg hat gerade wieder einmal einen
renten parteitag verschoben weil sie
sich nicht einigen kann
das heißt auch da hat mal eine
protesthaltung und das dritte thema ist
immer noch und das konstituiert die afg
in ihrer jetzigen form jahr die
sogenannte grenzöffnung dieser auch
nicht gegeben hat durch angela merkel
sondern angela mehr
hat die grenzen nicht geschlossen 2015
auch auf diesem thema reitet die afg man
muss sagen immer noch ihrer erfolgswelle
vor allem im osten und alle drei themen
11 es geht um dagegen es gibt keine
eigenen konzepte der afg dafür und
solange sie die nicht vorlegen kann
solange die afg nicht für ideen steht
für konzepte so lange kann sie sich
nicht volkspartei nennen
es ist jetzt aber auch schon so dass die
leute uns schreiben
sorry ist ist so das es geht ist es
nicht nur gefühlt so uns geht es im
osten schlechter wir sind vergessen
worden
dagegen wehren sich die menschen
schreibt julia müller auf facebook und
früher war es die linke jetzt fehlt mir
die afg um auf sich aufmerksam zu machen
ist das nicht auch ein stück wird
nachvollziehbar dass man wenn man dieses
gefühl hat dann tatsächlich eine partei
wählt die einfach immer nur dagegen
schreibt ist eine gute frage aber die
afg macht ja eben das habe ich jetzt
eben in der antwort erstmal weggelassen
weil ich mich genau so etwas gerechnet
habe nicht nur aus als sie dagegen
schreibt sondern die afg macht ja auch
ganz gezielt stimmung es gibt ja teile
der afd
die ganz gezielt ressentiments schürt
und zwar gegen flüchtlinge wenn man
diesen reden da am freitag zugehört hat
gab es nie das wort flüchtlingen in der
sonder es gab immer nur die formulierung
so genannte flüchtlinge das heißt man
spricht diesen menschen die nach
deutschland beziehungsweise nach europa
kommen auch den status darauf ab
flüchtlinge zu sein und zwar per sie
also ja unzufriedenheit sicherlich es
gibt sicherlich ist es immer so schwer
zu beziffern
ein teil der wähler der afg die aus
unzufriedenheit mit den etablierten
parteien wählen aber die müssen eben
auch wissen sie wählen auch eine partei
die nicht ohne grund vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird als
verdachtsfall
und wie das weitergeht das gucken wir
uns nicht nur auf jeden fall an
es gibt noch einige fragen aber wir
müssen noch ein bisschen auf die zeit
gucken deswegen entschuldige ich mich
dafür dass wir sie nicht alle
beantworten können nicole ich danke dir
dafür dass du gewartet hast dass thomas
fertig war und dass uns die fragen
beantwortet hat heute abend euch danke
ich dass wir dabei geblieben seid die
nächsten live stream bei uns gibt es am
donnerstag
um 20 30 auf den bekannten kanälen und
nochmal die bitte wenn ihr youtuber seid
lasst uns doch ein abo da auf dem zdf
heute kanal da freuen wir uns darüber in
dem sinne sache ich bis später und
tschüss
[Musik]